welcome to Table Talk where each week on
impact insights and ideas from Christian
theology spirituality culture that help
you become more thoughtful calm and just
a downright great human being my name is
Brett silver pastor at the table at
church in sexy Texas and today I wanna
offer you part 3 of my series why I'm a
gay affirming Christian basically in
this series I'm unpacking and why I
believe that it's not a sin to be gay
and that LGBTQ people in and one-to-one
committed marital relationships are not
in sin and thus should be fully included
and the life and leadership of the
church just like anyone else
so of course the the biggest sort of
hindrance or critique of my position
historically in a Christian context
certainly stems from our reading of
certain biblical passages so with that
in mind in this video and then the next
few probably least the next three I'd
like to start to unpack some of these so
today I want to jump into two Old
Testament texts that are commonly held
up as sort of proof texts proof that God
finds LGBT people to be not not really
merely just in sin but the text really
goes beyond that it would say there's
something like an abomination they're
sort of monstrous and or at least what
they're doing is a monstrous sin now
you'll notice today these are the only
Old Testament texts I'm an early get
into there's some others from like a
book of Genesis the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah and such that I'm just kind of
moving beyond that's mainly because in
the modern conversation around the Bible
and being gay and such those those other
texts don't really hold much weight
mainly because they're pretty clearly
about rape and no one really debates
whether rape is bad or not that's just
not a conversation so anyway that's why
I'm not really getting into those if
you'd like to message
I didn't send you some thoughts or
whatever but you know focusing in on
here okay so let me explain specifically
why I gave affirming Christian like
myself doesn't agree that Leviticus 18
and 20 of these two texts kind of point
to people being some doing some sort of
monstrous thing so before I jump in
nobody offered quick caveats inevitably
when I begin talking about how we
interpret the Bible people cry foul they
say look I'm not interested in
such-and-such scholars or your
interpretation of the Bible I just want
the truth I don't want the confusions of
men but the clarity of Scripture so if
that's you you need to go back and watch
my two previous table tongue because
because you see you and I don't simply
read the Bible for its plain meaning we
are just human beings and we interpret
the Bible right that's true for anyone
so in it becomes particularly important
that we understand that when we're
dealing with a very ancient text set in
a wildly different cultural context and
it's so it's important that we need
almost doubly triply careful that we're
not simply assuming what that's talking
about is exactly what we today the 21st
century are talking about so we have to
be careful of that okay so enough of
breakfast on to our texts a little bit
it's chapter 18 verse 22 says this you
shall not lie with a male as with a
woman it is an abomination
similarly Leviticus chapter 20 verse 13
says if a man has sexual relations with
a man as one does with a woman both of
them have done what is detestable they
are to be put to death their blood will
be on their own heads in other words
their own fault they had a comment now
let's notice that this text it just
called for the death of people
participating in gay sex so
be going on here and might the text not
have in mind Rick and Carl or sue and
Rachel down the street living their
quiet married life or might something
else be going on so coming back to my
previous video in the scholar James
Brown says idea that what the Bible says
is very clear why it says it and what
the moral logic is that's a whole
different matter in a whole at a level
of understanding but it's an important
thing that we understand so that we know
how to translate how to shouldn't say
translate but how to apply and interpret
it and interpret and then apply it
before today so let's go back and look
at some of the context what what did
same-sex errata sysm interactivity look
like in the broader Canaanite culture
which really provided Israel's cultural
context in into which is real and in the
right of the Bible were likely kind of
in conversation within to some degree
reacting against now based on the work
of a scholar his name's Martin nice
seein in his book homoeroticism in the
biblical world homoeroticism basically
in Canaan likely happened if not
exclusively almost exclusively within
the context of pagan and cultic temple
prostitution and i seethen writes these
words quote the surprising reference to
child sacrifice in a list of sexual
offenses strengthens the impression that
there is a cultic in other words a
religious kind of system background here
it has been commonly assumed therefore
that the writers of the holiness code
this would be books like Leviticus
associated homoerotic behavior
with sex connected to cultic religious
practices so for example what was he
talking about there that whole reference
to child sacrifice well the command of
Leviticus 18:22 you shall not lie with a
male as with a woman that is preceded by
verse 21 no wild right which in verse 21
says you shall not give any of your
children to sacrifice them to Molech
now Mallick was a Canaanite deity that
people would sort of disgustingly
sacrifice their kids to it was a
religious cult ritual and so this is
what I seen in his name II saying
because that perverse 21 persons right
before verse 22 and it's talking about
child sacrifice and such many scholars
have kind of said okay the context of
some of these this passage it is likely
cultic religion and religious no more
traditionalist folks on this topic will
kind of push back and say ah but you're
speculating you know obviously verse 21
was about child sacrifice and that's you
know religious and cultic agreed but
perhaps the verse 22 wasn't I mean maybe
verse 22 really is referring to Brickton
Karl the gay couple down the street and
maybe the moral logic was not temple
prostitution is bad see that's the logic
I think is they're actually trying to
push back on but instead of
traditionalist on the stomach might say
no that's not the moral logic I think
it's something like you know the failure
to act out one's appropriate gender role
is to go against God's created order
right now notice both of us are having
to do a little a little bit of
speculation a little bit of
interpretating interpretating interpret
teen as we kind of get at the moral
logic of the text right because we're
all I mean we're all interpreting now
here's some
kind of response this is James brownson
and his book Bible gender and sexuality
kind of pushing back on that more
traditionalist interpretation of the
neurologic he points out that if this
objection were true you know it's all
about living out your proper gender
roles and that's what Leviticus 18:22
and Leviticus 20 verse 13 are really
getting at
then what Bronson points out he says
well if that were the case though what
we would expect is a corresponding
prohibition of female female sexual
relations in the Book of Leviticus right
like it just says manual and yet of
course that's that's lacking there it's
only male in other words if the
underlying moral logic isn't cultic
religious cultural religious as I'm
arguing and it is in fact a focused upon
the failure of the genders and to live
out their God ordained biological
sexuality or something well then why
stop at provability men why not mention
women too now this point I think gains
extra force when we note that there's
some other prohibitions in these st.
chapters for example verse 23 of 18 so
right after our text verse 22 into 23
and then in Leviticus chapter 20 verses
15 16 both mentioned men and women in
now the context there as I recall is
it's in the prohibition of sex with
animals right so all of a sudden there
is talking about men don't do this women
don't do this but when it's coming to
the same gender sexuality which is as
men so either the biblical writer had no
idea about female female sexuality or at
least that wasn't a thing or it just
wasn't a thing in terms of temple
prostitution which I think that's the
more likely thing in other words I'm
suggesting that based on what we know
about same sex practices in the broader
Canaanite culture combined with the
reference to Molech and the preceding
verse of chapter 18 and verse 21
I believe the context for the verses
against same gender
opportunity in Leviticus 18 and chapter
20 is likely that there's some sort of
strange pagan temple prostitution ritual
going on now all that you might say
Brett you're speculating why not just
keep it straightforward and simple I
don't need to understand the
homosexuality in the broader Tanana
culture to understand the Bible well
here's the thing remember my previous
videos and there I talked about how
taking that approach to the topic of for
example slavery led us as churches to
some incredibly I mean at best naive at
worst I mean just terrible hurtful
interpretations why because we had
people saying things like slavery is
slavery slavery right don't you try to
go back and muddle the truth of God's
Word by bringing in the cultural context
of slavery in the broader Canaanite
culture like you're just trying to be
slippery here's the thing no no I'm not
trying to be slippery I think we're just
trying to be wise now might I be wrong
sure I'm sure of course some human being
right I mean when we're talking about
studying ancient cultures we're
inevitably doing some speculating right
and trying to say okay what's the
cultural context and then you know this
scholar that's got like and so I think
with that in mind we're we are doing
some speculating having said that I
still think it makes doing this kind of
work though it just makes the most sense
right to do some scholarly work to say
okay what was the broader context I just
think it makes it not a hundred percent
foolproof but it just makes it more
likely that we'll actually understand
the culture understand the Bible and
then
make a better interpretation for today
so all that to say I think same gender
pagan temple prostitution I think that's
bad because you know I think
prostitution is bad and I also think
that was a relevant concern in the
ancient world which is why the Bible is
just you know the writers are clearly
really amped up over this and
criticizing it rightly so however I
don't think that issue so to speak is
one that maps well into the 21st century
and the discussions we're having in the
church about who should be married or
preach a sermon so and my next video
I'll dive into some of the New Testament
texts since you know for many people the
Old Testament anyway doesn't really
carry quite the the weight of the New
Testament so that's all for today if you
enjoyed this video please like it share
while your friends comment and subscribe
grace in peace